hello everybody I'm Greg Proops I'm
going to show you how to make a martini
this recipe is by Louis buñuel the great
filmmaker and this is how it starts
first we get a shaker and some ice here
this is from the The Comedy Central ice
machine located right
if the cube hits the floor that's what
children are for they are your
indentured servants I wanted them to
pick it up we'll start with a little
vermouth here as you can see this is at
midnight premiere it's a very special
brand we pour about I don't know two
three ounces of vermouth into the shaker
and then white James Bond gently gently
gently and then Oh No are we playing
more vodka internet right on top of
remove no we're not and this is the
trick that unwellness that goes out that
way
this is scintilla a job an iota a
reminiscence of vermouth because you
don't want the remove to get in the way
of what the main event is which is this
flying peak seven vodka made by a very
good friend of ours here at the show my
strength is enormous so I'm just going
to rip the cork out oh when I smell
there we go hmm now they've given us a
shot glass to measure out the shots of
vodka and what we do with that is before
you get going you're going to want to oh
oh no that's good peak seven you don't
want to measure what you want to do is
do it by intuition couple more cubes of
ice here and then
okay not enough for me a little shake I
like to olives maybe three so we'll
start with to stick those right in there
that goes in first
maybe open then the main event right on
top
this will win you into anyone's heart
it's the perfect martini because there's
a hint of women not that big splashy
inky cuddle of a route that you want you
want this to be an elegant drunk because
after one you're going to be like Oh
have another one and then after two
you're going to be like I want anyone
inside me smashing that that's how you
make Louie Banuelos martini and I thank
you